good afternoon everybody
and welcome to this meeting of
mid-suffolk district council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley leader of
mid-suffolk district council
may i please remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you wish to speak
and not post comments or questions and
please note the messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by people watching
the live
broadcast i would like to remind
everyone present that this meeting will
be broadcast live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i will now ask the government's officer
to carry out the introductions
thank you chair in addition to the
cabinet members
we have councillor eban council of field
and councillor welum
joining us today also joining us
are the chief executive the strategic
director and the monitoring officer
thank you thank you can i move to the
agenda now please
item one is apologies for absence
we have no apologies chair thank you
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members
are there any to declare
no thank you item three
is mca 20 35
is confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting of the mid-south cabinet meeting
held on the 8th of february 2021.
are there are there any points regarding
the accuracy of the minutes
can i have a proposal please
counselor whitehead proposing
and councillor flatman seconding
thank you um so can i
now ask the governance officer to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members if you can
select the plus sign on the top right
hand corner of your mod gov app
the vote for the minutes is now in
progress
thank you chair that's nine votes for
that's unanimous
thank you very much so the minutes of
the meeting have been confirmed and will
be signed at the next practicable
opportunity
item four to receive notification of
petitions in the courts for the
council's petition scheme
non-received chair thank you
item five questions by councillors
non-received chair
you item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or the joint audit
and standards committee
i'll now invite councillor wellam chair
of the overview and scrutiny committee
to introduce the report
thank you chair on the 15th of february
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee
received and reviewed the local citizens
advice service
we received a report from the corporate
manager communities
and a presentation from the three chief
executive officers of mid-suffolk
sudbury and ipswich citizens advice
committee noted that the citizens advice
service to i
had not been provided from dis and
thetford ca
during the current year and mid-suffolk
ca are putting in place
an outreach service into the former bank
members suggested that the funding
allocated to but not claimed by dis
and thetford uh citizen's advice should
be reallocated to mid-suffolk citizens
advice
as the sole citizens advice provider in
mid-suffolk
committee heard how workload at cas had
increased during lockdown
there were many reasons for this
including
a reduction in residence income due to
furloughing
and reduced working hours redundancy
debt due to loss of income fear of loss
of home
stress caused by spending more time
indoors with family members
fear of abuse and actual abuse and
lack of facilities for home schooling
also the temporary closure of our
customer access points
made a difference to their workload and
the loss of free school meals gave
pressures
uh they added pressures due to having
sort of the extra expense and also the
extra effort in providing the meals
um cas had incurred additional costs for
providing it
for working from home and screens etc
which they had to put up in the office
because they did have some face-to-face
consultations
committee also heard how ca income from
some of their
regular funders would not be forthcoming
in 2021-22
and mid-suffolk community advice had us
funding shortfall for the next
that for the next year
members agreed that they had they
that they had anticipated that cias
would have a three-year funding
agreement
index linked but there seemed to be some
uncertainty
as to whether or not the index linking
was being applied for 2021-22
at the end of a lengthy debate the
recommendations set out
on page 15 were agreed
these are that the overview and scrutiny
committee is satisfied
and notes the content of the report and
commend the work of the mid-suffolk
local citizens advice
and also the ipsw citizens advice and
the sudbury district
local citizens advice and
recommendation 1.2 that the joint
overview and scrutiny
confirmed the previous resolution made
at last review
that the three-year rolling funding
arrangements review
be subject to indexation on an annual
review basis
finances permitting as a measure of the
importance we attach to ongoing
local citizens advice funding
thank you chair thank you councillor
william
so this report is just for noting and
the issue of index
linking will be discussed as part of a
wider review
with everybody who receives
our major grant grants
as part of an ongoing discussion
thank you very much item
7 is the forthcoming decisions list
does anybody have any comments
item eight is mca
20 37 and is the general fund
financial monitoring report for quarter
three for 2020 to 21.
i'll now invite the cabinet member for
finance to introduce this
this report thank you madam chairman
i'm pleased to introduce report mca 2037
on the general fund monitoring which
extrapolates the likely out turn for
this financial year based on our actual
financial performance
through the first nine months of the
year as i repeat every time
i introduce one of these financial
monitoring pools it is important
that we keep a close eye on our
expenditure to date against budget
and then carry out a thorough assessment
to forecast the outcome for the whole
year
this year our finances have been so
complicated by the impact of covert
the additional cost we've incurred and
the general assistance
generous assistance given by central
government
in pulling together this report the
finance team have worked hard to put
some really detailed narrative against
all these many facets
narrative that runs to well over three
pages of the report
from paragraphs 5.1 to 5.12.
the detailed variances are then set out
in tabular form in paragraph 6.6
which concludes with an anticipated out
turn being a surplus of 1.817 million
which is a significant improvement over
that forecasted when the exercise was
carried out at the end of quarter two
my personal view is that the format of
this out turn report
and that's a formula that's been tried
and tested over many normal years
is not well suited to a situation where
the government assistance
has come in left right and center to so
many of our income streams
and cost centers so when the dust is
settled and we report the actual outcome
of 21
2021 we will look to see if there is a
clearer format in which to report and
present this unprecedented year
before hopefully we return to more
normality going forward
the main items that increase the
anticipated surplus but beyond what we
forecast
at the q2 out turn are firstly
167 000 pound less car parking income
secondly 370 000 more planning fee
income including that for a proposed
large
solar pv farm third 259 000 more
covalent expenditure
for 157 000 msdc
leisure contract saving and the largest
item
764 000 additional business rates
and these five items account for 94
of the improvement the report
also sets out in detail our capital
program with the spend to date
the full year forecast and the details
expected carry forward
the numbers are in appendix d with
supportive narrative in paragraph
614 to 616. appendices
also set out our reserve position and
the details
of the continuing projects within our
growth and efficiency fund
the table papers also show revised and
now corrected totals
at the bottom appendix b at this point
prior to the year end and establishing
the final outcome for the year
the variances are just for noting the
numbers will undoubtedly change again
as there remains inherent uncertainty
still within the final quarter
i mean just today for example we are
recommencing garden waste collection
which wasn't envisaged when this report
was written but i'm pleased to move the
recommendations
to the effect of noting as set out in
paragraph 3.1
i'll be happy to answer any questions
arising from the report
we'll ask for someone to second these
recommendations thank you
thank you councillor gould
thank you very much sir madam chair and
um
it's a pleasure to uh second the
recommendation
uh in in in this report and to
express uh thanks uh to councillor
whitehead
uh for his presentation of the report
and indeed for the
for the report itself uh i think once
again
there's little to say in a sense about a
financial position it's been
fairly well discussed not least in terms
of our recent budget setting
uh meeting um but it is worth i think
repeating thanks to the finance team
for their diligence and hard work uh
throughout the
year and i note what council whitehead
says about the way
in which the the government promised
government support has appeared
but um personally i think let's just be
thankful there was so much of it uh
even though and that it appeared at all
uh
and it has helped though as councilwhite
has said there's a number of other items
that have helped improve our position uh
tremendously uh so i very much like to
second report
thank you very much madam chair thank
you councillor gould
do we have any questions
councillor eben
thank you very much chair and thank you
john for your
report um councillor whitehead sorry
for your report um i just wanted to ask
on page 27 it refers to the um
high amount the 450 000 pound
of variances due to um staff management
as in
vacancies um and i just wondered if you
we could have a little bit more
explanation on that
um particularly when when um
you know we know we're in a situation
where lots of people have probably
might have lost their jobs at the moment
and therefore be looking for work
um and also from the fact that we might
you know ourselves as a council be
wanting kind of
you know another tree officer some
enforcement support or
or housing to to update policies and so
on so i just wondered if we could
understand
you know why that variance is so high
thank you very much thank you
i mean i'll bring in our ceo in a moment
but i'll just say that
obviously period comes from the first of
april through to december
and a large part of that obviously was
the first lockdown
and all the difficulties that that that
created um so
i feel there are valid reasons why
recruitment had to be put on hold but
if our ceo wants to add to that i'm
happy to
that i think as the white hood has
largely said it all but but absolutely
the the the impact of lockdown did have
uh some slowdown in our ability to
recruit that not entirely so we we have
been able to do recruitment
through the periods of the various
periods of lockdown but it's been very
different it's been remote
virtual type recruitment um been
successful but clearly is
is a slower process in terms of
replacing staff where there are
vacancies
we also went into the pandemic with a
higher than usual level
of vacancy rates as a result of the
management review that had been carried
out the year before
um so we'd come to the end of that
period of time and we had some vacancies
they hadn't yet been appointed to so we
were
carrying at slightly higher than normal
numbers of vacancies as we went through
that process
but really as castle whitehead says this
is a backwards look doesn't have any
impact in terms of what we are there
now doing in terms of uh bringing
forward other posts
either to replace existing vacancies or
indeed
to create new new posts that would be in
addition to the existing complement of
staff
thanks very much for that so so we're
confident we'll see a much lower
level of vacancies
going forward confident yes barring all
other things that could always happen to
us so
uh certainly i would assume uh that we
would see a more
normal level of vacancy turnover because
that's basically what draws that
drives the vacancy rate is to do with
the level of turnover
and staff we've seen a huge amount of
loyalty
and commitment from our staff through
the pandemic and so i'm confident that
will continue
but clearly people retire people move on
and so if that remains at sort of normal
levels then then yes
we would see a reduction in terms of the
the percentage year on year
uh if for any reason that would have
changed then obviously it would go up
slightly higher
it's almost inevitable i would say that
uh we're in a situation more often than
not where when somebody leaves there is
a delay before the new person can join
uh just because of the practicality they
might give us a month's notice but by
the time we've been out to advert
advertised and then they need to give a
month's notice to their current employer
that there's always a little bit of a
gap
we try and avoid that where we can but
clearly it's not not always possible
more often than not it's more manageable
when we know there's a planned
retirement
then obviously we can we can manage that
and try and avoid any gap and preferably
have a bit of a handover which will be
even better which would then help
mitigate some of those costs
of cost savings um but yes um as far as
i can be confident yes i think we can
expect to see that come down a bit this
year
thanks for that and i certainly agree
about the loyalty of existing staff but
thanks very much for that thank you
thank you very much uh councillor field
thank you um the business rates
position i was just going to check i i
understood a big chunk of the business
rates
variances were due to a payment
for the electrical infrastructure at um
in bronford i
notice here that you've reported um uh
404k expected from the business rates
pool
i just wondered whether i it could be
made clear why
um the large sum of money we received in
bradford was not disappearing into the
business rates pool
is that 404k what remains after such a
transfer
because the pool has grown or what is
there something i'm missing
thank you i'm going to invite in a
moment melissa evans to
to answer that detailed question can i
just check i just
apologized and reserve it because i
don't think i had my camera on dinner
whilst i was uh
giving giving my introductory speech so
i apologize if that was the fact
i do tend to listen out
thank you thank you chair um yeah thank
you council phil for your question
um i can confirm that actually that
benefit into the business rates pool it
does include the
uh branford power station coming online
as well so that has been
shared amongst the uh the other topical
authorities and that's the element we
get to keep out of that
so that is included in there okay thank
you
just don't don't want to be negative
about it
but they're large sums of money thank
you
thank you um so i'm now going to open up
the item for debate
does anybody wish to say anything
[Music]
no the report is just for noting so
i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic
vote
thank you chair members once again if
you select
the plus in the top right hand corner of
your app the vote is now in progress
just waiting for two more votes
thank you members chair that's nine
votes for that's carried
lovely thank you very much
moving on to item nine this is mca
20 38 and it's the housing revenue
account financial monitoring
report for 2020 to 2021
quarter three councillor whitehead
thank you madam chairman i'll just check
i got my camera on and
i'm not reading out the previous
introduction
right i'm pleased to now give a brief
introduction to the housing revenue
account quarter three financial
monitoring report
again as with the general fund this is
based on nine months numbers
then extrapolated to the year end
year-end surplus of 2.193 million is
anticipated in contrast to the 5
64 000 deficit budgeted a table showing
these variances by line item is set out
in paragraph 6.3
with the narrative behind these
variances set out in paragraphs
6.6 to 610 by far the largest variance
is the 2.604 million
favorable variance arising because we
have not had to make
a revenue contribution to capital but
this figure is unchanged from the q
2 outlook which i reported back in
december and in the main part of my
introductory speech then
i set out a detailed explanation for
this variant so i won't repeat all that
again
however i'm pleased to report that one
large adverse variance forecasted in the
q2 outlook
being a significant rental increase
sorry rental income shortfall
and tenants has been eliminated in this
updated outlook
it is explained in paragraph 5.2 and is
now in line with the view that i
expressed in december when i said that i
was hopeful that the shortfall predicted
then would actually just prove to be
very prudent assessment
that the bulk of those rents do will
ultimately be recovered
albeit perhaps over a longer time frame
than this current financial year
paragraph 5.1 refers to additional covet
19
costs for ppe of 46 000
these have been covered in their
entirety by the corona various response
fund that we received from central
government
on the capital side there's been a
significant slippage on the build
programme
we are now anticipating a capital carry
forward on new building acquisitions
of seven million two hundred thirty
three thousand now that assumes that
over nine million is spent in q4
with a substantial program of house
acquisitions being completed
i'd like to acknowledge the great deal
of effort and hard work
undertaken by officers ensuring that our
right to buy receipts
are being spent before the expiry of the
government extended national deadline
so as with the general fund the various
at this stage prior to year end are just
for noting
the recommendation in paragraph three is
worded accordingly
i'd therefore like to move the
recommendations set out in paragraph
three
with us academy member for housing
council loving them if you were kindly
second these recommendations
collectively with the housing ad and
finance officers present
we'd be happy to answer any questions
arising on this report
thank you joslyn
thank you yes i'm very happy to second
this report and i would just like to
take the opportunity again to thank the
housing team for the marvelous hard work
they do
and also for emily atack for all the
works he's done the right to buy
receipts
thank you thank you
i now open up for questions
anybody like to put their hand up
counselor field
sorry that's an old hand
okay no questions and so i now open it
up for debate
anybody wish to debate this item i think
i
i would just like to add my my thanks
to the housing team as well and
especially to
emily attack and her team around
the massive effort that they put into um
[Music]
making sure that our right to buy was
all in order
by the deadline because that was that
was quite a mission to undertake and
really do appreciate that thank you
councillor gould
simply to absolutely endorse some second
did it
what you just said i think it was um
a fantastic piece of work fantastic
accomplishment
and and it deserves all the recognition
it can get
thank you very much
so i will now ask the governance officer
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair members your vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that's unanimous nine
votes for
thank you very much
so i'm now moving on to item 10 which is
mca
20 39 and is the quarter three
performance report
book performance presentation
council tax hardship fund
i'm just going to invite
our assistant director to
um talk us through this report thank you
thank you madam chairman good afternoon
councillors
yes like to introduce you to our quarter
three performance presentation
covering period october through to
december
you'll see that this presentation
follows our new style which was
introduced at the beginning of this
financial year and is focused on our
six key priorities from the corporate
plan as well as our health of the
organization which
illustrates some key themes which ensure
the councils are working efficiently and
effectively
taken in its entirety the report seeks
to provide some high level assurance
that the councils are delivering against
the corporate plan
highlighting some key performance
measures and progress
against objectives with a look forward
to planned activity in our next
quarter as is usual i don't intend to
run through the entirety of both
presentations
as there's quite a lot of detail in
there but i would just like to highlight
a couple of themes
that are relevant the first of which is
our desire to continuously improve
and review the format and content i
think it's fair to say that with every
iteration we are making some progress
both in terms of content as well as
engagement with colleagues across the
council
that's not to say though that i think
there is more we can do to make some
improvements
we certainly will be working with
colleagues to focus on outcomes rather
than pure narrative on what we have been
doing
and we also want to maintain a focus on
quality rather than
quantity one of the aims when we
developed the new style if you recall
was to try and keep it concise and to
move away from the pages and pages of
content that we expected everybody to
digest
and certainly in this quarter three i
can see that we've added a bit to the
page count
and for the final quarter i'll be
certainly working with teams
across the council to address this
we also want to continue to try and
bring these presentations to life with a
much more
interactive content and individual case
studies
a second theme is obviously the impact
that the
pandemic has had during quarter three
and continues to have on us
resulting in a heavy focus on copied
response work
unsurprisingly our attentions are
diverted which means some objectives and
activity has slowed
or paused and we have tried to reflect
this in the presentations where this has
happened
but equally explaining what activity has
taken place instead
you'll see this most noticeably in the
well-being objective for example
so that's just by way of a brief summary
happy to hand back to the chair for any
questions
and comments thank you thank you very
much
does anybody have any questions
no so oh
councillor eben
thank you very much chair um and thank
you to um
sarah wilcock for that um presentation
from the work that she
does put in because i know it's it's
very detailed and
a lot of work across the organization
but one one of the aspects that i bring
up
regularly is about our social measuring
social value and the social return on
investment
and with the outcomes that the council
is trying to achieve
um i just wonder where we're at with
actually being able to measure that in
terms of
social return on investment thank you
very much chair
thank you sarah
thank you councillor ebern for your for
your question
yes certainly social value and and
measuring that
impact is something that we absolutely
have as a as a priority moving forward
we do appreciate that that's one of the
significant ways that we can
bring to life and and bring to light the
the impact of the work that goes on
across the organization which isn't
necessarily readily available in the in
the measures that we currently use
there's obviously a much greater impact
that we can see by
by taking on some measurements of social
value so
happy to say that that is on our
priority list moving forward but just is
something that we've not got to yet at
the moment but
it's certainly something that we'll be
looking to include in future iterations
thank you very much i look forward to
that thank you you
thank you councillor field
thank you a long long report to scroll
up and down rapidly
looking for things questioned um i'm
sure you'll find the
the increase of 28 in compliments
received something that's uh
cheering to say not to complain about
but i was looking at the 160 complaints
below that
uh 18 down on quarter two has got to be
good um it says 74
were not upheld and of those that
were so that's 26 or so
consisted of one-off errors or process
improvements investigated uh or
instigated so so so are you sort of
suggesting there is absolutely no
problem there at all 160 people
complained
not upheld by our own investigation
process but seem really
just a few more words around that would
help just how do we see that
because 160s has quite a lot compared
with 77
compliments thank you sarah
thank you councillor field for for your
question
um obviously it's not to belittle any
complaints that
that we receive and they are all taken
uh very seriously
and looked at in detail by independent
um colleagues in the organization and
corporate managers responsible for those
particular services
i think it's fair to say that there is a
proportion of complaints that we receive
that are sometimes
in relation to the actual service that
that they might have
requested so for example a missed bin
could could perhaps
relate to um to a complaint
i'm happy to um to go away and provide
you some further assurance and detail
around
around those and we do report complaints
on a quarterly basis to the senior
leadership team
as well so happy to to pull that
together for you and
share that with you um obviously there
are some things that do get
um that do get looked at that do
mean that we do want to change a process
and
and take or take on board
a policy or a process change and that's
part and parcel of us trying to learn
directly from customer feedback as to
how we can make improvements in services
going going forwards
so whilst it's great that we've had a
decrease in
in complaints we do keep a close eye on
that
moving forwards um but you know
are keen to obviously make those process
improvements as as we go along and that
information is is shared
each time that we review a complaint
with the service
that um that it's attributed to
thank you so the process improvement
instigated is after the complaint it's
not sort of suggesting we've already
got there or no it's as a result of the
complaint this
something has brought something that
hasn't worked very well to light and
we've taken that opportunity to work
with the service to suggest some
improvements to it
okay okay that sounds good thank you
thank you councillor willem
thank you chair i'm on the same page the
customer feedback the website feedback
bar
it's suggested there that the feedback
is about the service rather than
about the website how i don't understand
how we know that it's about
the the service rather than about the
website somebody could explain that
because
things like waste collections that are
missed
usually they're rectified so quickly
that i don't understand
from my own experience how they would be
a a complaint about that but i can
understand that
people will find the website difficult
to use in order to
um to to report a missed waste
collection
so if we can be sure that it's about the
website
and not about the um the service i'd be
grateful
or vice versa thank you
sarah thank you very much councillor
welland
for your inquiry there um i think it's
fair to say that 2.26 out of 5
is is not a level that we we want to see
we we want to see that
a lot higher and we did undertake quite
a bit of improvement work
over the summer of last year trying to
make our site more accessible in line
with some
new government regulations that that
came out
and we continue to work with individual
service areas
to look at the content that they have on
the site to make sure that it's up to
date
and it's written in plain english and is
easily accessible
i think it's fair to say that we do we
see receive a mixed bag of
complaints through the customer feedback
tool so
people do have the ability to put free
text comment
when they rate their experience using
the emojis that are available
and we do find that the free text
comments do
sometimes relate to the actual service
itself
so for example they might pop in that
comment box that
they're not happy that their bin wasn't
collected or
that a planning application was granted
and
so the the feedback tool does relate to
those
um sort of comments as well as people
perhaps who have found the website
not as easy and intuitive to use as we
would like
thank you chair i've got um some queries
about
um the communities and about well-being
would you like me to
carry on yes i mean they're fairly
straightforward i think
and i recognize that communities have
been so busy with uh kobe 19 grants and
so on
which rightly were given a very high
priority and i think they did
brilliant work on on that front during
the pandemic
and so there were possibly fewer bids
being made for grants
um but i'm trying to understand the
position
um in respect of the it's just gone from
my screen
um the the the grants where it says that
sixty percent of annual capital grant
has been allocated
uh it doesn't say how much of that has
been
has been spent it says yeah it's offered
but not
not spent um that's quite a high
figure uh if it's not if it isn't spent
um and um quite quite
only quite a small portion there's still
quite a significant portion that
hasn't been allocated is that is that
still
the position on the uh on grants
um and the the total funding
offered um how much has now been spent
you know what what's going to happen to
the underspent
uh and um could i have an update if it
is at all possible on locality grants i
see at the end of december
only 50 percent of that had been spent
or less than 50 percent
who wants to take this question
uh i think what we'll do counselor
william oh
cathy yes indeed counselor wellum thank
you for your question
um first of all in terms of locality
grants um no
they haven't all been spent and um of
course
members have to the 31st of march um to
do that
and i would um really encourage members
across the board
um to be getting um those um bids in
in terms of um the um amount of money
offered against what has now been spent
um we will need to take that away um and
reply
and outside outside the meeting
and in terms of um generally on grants
in terms of the underspend
and more widely and we still do have
bids coming in
at this point in time i saw one just
earlier this morning
thank you thank you and uh just a query
about the well-being strategy
um there's a reference to well the
well-being strategy is just one day
wondering when members and stakeholders
will have an
opportunity to con contribute to the
strategy and if there is a
a target for completing it and
there's lots of strands of work taking
place we can read about those
um and will all members be made aware of
what's going on
uh i i just i just think there's a lot
of work going on there
i guess it's all good work there's no
reason why it isn't all good work
um and it would be good to um
know a bit more about it and and and
also for members
and stakeholders to have a new input
into it may not be something you can
answer
just now but a bit more around the
way the the strategy is being developed
would be very useful please
thank you kathy do you want to take that
one
i i can i can make um some response to
that
and yes there will be um further member
engagement
in terms of um the well-being strategy
over the next few months
um which will build of course on the um
initial member engagement that there was
in 2020
and where we invited um all members and
to a couple of workshops and and
i don't have the exact date to hand but
and we would expect that the well-being
strategy
and will be completed and during the
summer
at some point could i just one one last
question um can we try to make sure that
there's
that there are there are actions in
respect of encouraging
cycling and walking because there was
such an increase in
cycling and walking during the lockdown
and i think we've got something there
that we can build on it would just be a
shame if we didn't
take some action fairly quickly and
throughout the the the coming summer to
to build on that
thank you very much chair thank you and
and these
these uh workshops will not happen prior
to the elections so they'll be after
after that thank you thank you kathy
um who else have we got councillor bern
um into jim um i
i'd like to ask a question uh probably
more for the benefit of any members the
public who might be
watching our meeting it's it's
how how widely are these performance
reports circulated i mean clearly
um they are put in the public domain
as part of the papers that uh uh
go out for these uh for these meetings
that we have in cabin with cabinet
um but beyond that uh is there any
circulation
available it's only circulation carried
out by our team
to any other any other recipients
not to my knowledge although councillors
are
are quite welcome to circulate them
amongst their
parish councils but um i'll ask sarah to
give a more detailed reply
sarah thank you councillor byrne
and yes councilman molly's right isn't
we there's not a massive circulation
uh list where we we send the report out
per se
we are looking to obviously make this a
report that is much
more easily sort of consumable by our by
our residents
which is why we're trying to bring it a
bit more to life with some case studies
and what i'd like to see moving forward
is um sort of more interactive videos
and and case studies that are presented
in a format which is much more engaging
so certainly something that we will be
looking uh to promote more while
more widely obviously are
they are published as part of any papers
and
in previous instances we have found that
the press
uh often will will pick up on certain
things that are included within the
report
and obviously that gets some circulation
then if it's if it's wildly
widely reported and so as we
as we continue to to make changes and
iterate this uh performance report
moving forward then um we absolutely
will be looking to extend its
its publication and hopefully have it in
a more engaging format that will be of
interest to
our residents and communities
thank you very much councillor field
thank you sorry to come back a couple of
points on the environment
sheet certainly the first one um
incidence of fly tipping 124 up from 86.
i just wondered uh what we're doing
about that
i mean it may be buried in the text but
the text is extremely small
somewhat forbidding um which may also uh
impact on your desire for other people
to read this
um so there's just a comment on that
please
and again similarly the 11.57 percent
recycling that was contaminated or too
small to process and one today is that
up or down or
sideways on on previous occasions and
again
what are we doing about that so both
those cases
really what action is is underway to
ensure those numbers
improve
thank you council field councillor
fleming would you like to respond to
that
um thank you thank you very much
chairman thank you councillor field
um these aren't difficult aren't easy
questions to answer
actually because during the pandemic we
have
seen a very marked increase in fly
tipping
and i think this is partly due to the um
perceive the difficulty of accessing the
bring
centers and the recycling centers
i think people who had been coming in
when you didn't have to schedule a trip
whereas most people are very happy to
book a slot
some people aren't and i think we're
seeing some people who are maybe
sort of slipping in with a few extra
things
um finding that it's more difficult to
get rid of their things and
leaving them by the side of the road etc
we do have a no-fly tipping campaign
going on we've seen a marked increase
in what i would call rogue
traders taking people's large items
and waste and offering to dispose of
them for a fee
and a lot of these people are not
registered
to deal in waste or scrap and they
simply take them
and leave them somewhere i have been
speaking with
our waste team and with suffolk trading
standards and in fact with the police
and this is something that it's very
unfortunate
what we really need is a few really good
prosecutions
and i think that's something we're all
trying to work towards and i have to say
our team has been remarkably good about
collecting evidence
but the courts are extremely behind you
probably know that there's about a year
and a half's wait
before a hearing can be brought to the
court in ipswich
to prosecute people so all of these
things are contributing
unfortunately to to what you see as an
increase in fly tipping
in terms of what can be done i think
actually ward councillors can play a
really important role
we've got a leaflet circulating and i
hope you've received a copy of it
to try to get the message out to
residents in anything you publish
that please if you must give your
waste to an entity other than mid
suffolk which there is a
you know i think it's 60 pounds a charge
for a large item pick up
um be a hundred percent sure that
they're legitimate and there are ways of
checking but they're also ways of
dodging the cheque
so that would be my message on that um
in terms of the recycling rate i think
possibly due to the just
the larger amount of recyclable
materials coming through people's homes
during the pandemic
there has been an increase in in
materials going into the recycling bin
that probably shouldn't have gone in
things like tetra packs
things like glass things like
small pieces of cardboard and we
probably do have
more to do in terms of getting that
message out
we have a get recycling right campaign
which is sponsored by the suffolk waste
partnership at the moment
there are flyers going around electronic
flies there are actually
physical copies of flyers available from
the waste service so
get in touch with me or ollie fares if
you would like actual copies
of the um get some get recycling right
flyers
some of the parishes are being um
equipped with these flies and they're
handing out to in their new residence
packs
because when new people come to suffolk
they sometimes aren't familiar with the
way we recycle here
and it's very useful to have a flyer to
put in their pack
other than that it's you know it's
difficult to know how we can
reduce the amount of of things going in
the
the recyclable waste stream that
unfortunately
are not recyclable i think um if uh and
if any of our waste team are on the line
and would like to add anything
or any of our officers online would like
to add anything to what i've said
i don't think they're they may not be
but um cancer field does that
go some way to responding to i think yes
thank you it does yeah it does
i mean one often wonders whether with
the fly tipping
uh you know if if we provided some
facilities where these people
could deposit stuff more easily
uh whether it would have any effect as
you say you know
were it that i had a something i want to
dispose of and i was
of the right mindset i might try and
avoid a 60 pound
fee by giving it to someone i know for a
while is going to dump it down the road
you know as counselors we wouldn't do
that would we but
wonder wonders how you change the
incentive that
people face and you know i've often
thought that one could put
as a parish we could put for instance a
skip in our village car park for for
you know one week every two months or
something and people get rid of stuff in
that way so
is there any innovative way we could
resolve the problem
you know i take the point about
punishment but that often doesn't work
in the case that's interesting actually
council field because
in order for you to do that as a parish
council your parish council would need
to be licensed with the department of
the environment
as a recycler and goodness we don't
actually do it then
it's just the ideas don't need licensing
thank you but there is possible can i
just add
um i think the um new
producer responsibility legislation
we'll probably come
see coming in the next year or so will
possibly
allow a longer term solution to this
problem
because i think what i what i personally
would like to see
is um the manufacturers and
sales points for the sorts of goods that
we find
dumped um paying upfront
so that we can provide more expensive
and easier to
use facilities for retrieving the items
when they come to the end of their life
um perhaps even attaching value to them
i think it's that circular economy
that we need to start to promote in a
much more real sense so that people
aren't inc you know incentivized to
throw things away wherever they
feel like it thank you yeah
thank you thank you councillor fleming
so that item
was for noting only
so i'm now going to move on to item 11
which is mca 20
40 and is the community infrastructure
levy expenditure program
for march 2021 and i'm going to invite
the cabinet member for planning to
introduce
this report thank you
thank you madam chairman um
this seal expenditure program contains
an update on progress on decisions in
bid rounds one to
six including decisions made in december
2020
also included is a list of emerging
projects for future consideration which
are currently developing
from the cabinet paper you'll see that
there are five bids on which a decision
is required
all five are for cabinet to make
um the uh details of these are given
extensively
in uh i think it's appendix b
um but there is an awful lot to plow
through there so for um
i will spend a bit of time uh going
through each one
uh to to bring you all up to speed on it
um the first one is m 20
hyphen 20 which is uh
the stone market creating road depot
this is our depot in
in stone market and this is from the
strategic infrastructure fund
and the project relates to the provision
of a new
uh hydrogen well hvo hydrogenated
vegetable oil
fuel tank or alter
hydrated sorry um vegetable oil
fuel tank alternative low carbon fuel
for
refusing recycling collection vehicles
this project provides a high carbon
impact saving it directly relates to the
district council's objectives
of the climate emergency declaration
the council's declared this climate
emergency in in
2019 and the
cabinet's carbon reduction management
plan was recently published proposal 4.3
of the plan states that we will secure
the transition of appropriate council
fleet vehicles
to electric or other zero carbon fuel
sources
such as hydro-treated vegetable oil
um hvo was as as we've
called it earlier on uh cabinet agreed
in principle
uh to this earlier in the year
the project represents the first step
towards this objective
and is acceptable waste infrastructure
which is specifically listed in the
infrastructure delivery plan and the
infrastructure funding statement
infrastructure list for mid-suffolk
that's the first uh the first item
the second is m 2024
which is uh gizlingham
school and community daily mile
running track and this is from the ring
fenced infrastructure fund
now gizzling and primary school would
like to provide additional
infrastructure
on the school site to improve exercise
facilities
and is committed to encourage active and
healthy lifestyles
the exercise track would enable pupils
staff parents and the wider community
to exercise more and improve the
facilities on the school
site particularly in wet weather
school staff would then be able to
introduce the daily mile as they call it
using the track to encourage daily
activity for all pupils
a school running club has also been
established and it runs once a week
before school
this has given that this is proven
popular
with both pupils and parents who can
also join in
but can only operate for half of the
year
the exercise track would enable the
running club club to operate
all year round the running track would
also be used by the wider community
including gizzling a netball team
gizzigam
informal running group and the playgroup
the completion of a community user
agreement will ensure that the use of
this facility
by the wider community is safeguarded
the amount of sale funding is regarded
as acceptable under the terms of the
sale expenditure framework
as the sill bid of 18 487 pounds 50
and represents 75 of the total project
costs and lies within the community
infrastructure thresholds
of not exceeding 75 000 pounds
and 75 of the total costs
this project has been developed on the
community community infrastructure
section
within the infrastructure funding
statement infrastructure list
within mid-suffolk
subject to the completion of a community
user agreement
this is recommended for approval by
cabinet
the third is m2023 this
is a health and administration hub and
clinical capacity recon
figuration at the mendelssohn surgery
and again this is from the local
infrastructure fund
this project aims to provide an extended
service to the community
of mendelssohn backton and the
surrounding area
there would be an increase of clinical
space which would allow for
other allied healthcare professionals
such as a clinical pharmacist
social prescribers physiotherapists
chiropodists
ultrasound phlebotomy and mental health
link workers
or counsellors to provide services to
the community using the new space which
will be provided
the practice hope that they will also be
able to attract hospital consultants to
have
outpatient clinics at mendelssohn which
would also benefit the community with
that service
on their doorstep instead of having to
travel to the local hospitals
the project also includes a newly
designed waiting room
and a larger dispensary capacity which
would also benefit
the community there is also the
opportunity that the additional services
which could be provided
would help to improve health prevention
well that doesn't mean health prevention
prevention of injurious impacts to
health
which would then have an impact on the
health care
which will be needed in the future
improved parking and cycling facilities
will be provided through this project
for the benefit of the community using
the practice
together with two new ev charging points
and cycle racks
the practice it's also providing funds
towards the project as well as the cell
bid
the project is supported by this
clinical commissioning group
the patient participation group and the
community
the project has planning permission and
is listed as essential infrastructure
within the infrastructure delivery plan
and is also contained in the
infrastructure funding statement
infrastructure list for mid-southwark
the fourth is in hawley and it is an
improvement and extension
of the ron kraskol pavilion car park
this project provides an overall
improvement regeneration and
revitalization project for king george's
field hawley
this will provide a safe sports
community and
leisure car park at the wrong classical
pavilion
by properly extending preparing and
servicing
existing ground currently used for
parking together with the construction
of 10 additional spaces the project has
local community
and ward and county member support and
is one of two syllabids that have been
received from this parish
to improve and upgrade this community
facility
the amount of self-funding is regarded
as acceptable under the terms of the
sill expenditure framework
has a sill bid of 22 595 pounds
and represents 67 percent of the total
project costs
and therefore lies within the community
infrastructure thresholds this project
has been delivered
under the community infrastructure
section within the infrastructure
funding statement infrastructure list
for mid software and finally
m20 hyphen 22 again in hawley
which is the provision of secure storage
facilities
at the wrong kraskol pavilion this
project provides a secure storage
facility
in the form of a separate building for
the organizations which
use the pavilion and playing fields
which includes local football
and bowls clubs scout group royal
british legion
and parish council the current storage
facility has previously been a target
for crime
and this project will satisfactorily
address crime risks
and seeks to increase the security of
storage facilities
and should address any future concerns
it has
the community and both district and
council county councillor support
the amount of sale funding is regarded
acceptable under the terms of the sale
expenditure framework
has the sale bid of 39 937 pounds
represents 50 of the total project costs
and therefore lies within the community
infrastructure thresholds
so the recommendation is i've set out in
your report paragraph 8.1
that cabinet is recommended to improve
the sell bids at stone market
gislingham mendelssohn and two separate
bids at hawley
and paragraph 3.2 the cabinet is asked
to note
and endorse the sill expenditure program
march 2021 thank you chairman i'm sorry
it's taken so long to
explain all that to you but i think it i
i did want to try and sell you
the individual bids because i think
they're all very worthwhile
thank you lovely thank you very much
councillor burn do we have a seconder
councillor brewster i'm happy to second
madam chairman
and also at the same time i had
forgotten that scouts were mentioned
on the uh on the
ron kraskel pavilion um the provision of
storage
so i should perhaps declare although i'm
president of stone market
district scouts i should perhaps declare
a non-pecuniary interest
in that thank you thank you for that
counselor brewster
do we have any questions from cabinet
members
no counselor eben
thank you very much much chair and and
it's um
not necessarily well it was part of a
question but um firstly i'd just like to
say thank you
very much to the staff in the seal team
for their support
of the volunteer groups in hawley their
their support has been exceptional
and they've been really the volunteer
groups actually said to me they're very
impressed with
the accessibility of the staff and their
dealings and and so on so
a big thank you to them and also
i should say thank you to the to the
volunteers that put together the the
bids in hawley because i think it's
quite
unusual in that it's five different
volunteer groups
coming together which really shows the
whole community working together in
order to improve the
facilities and i suppose if if i was to
ask a question it was to kind of say
that i do hope there'll be no changes to
the sil
um can you confirm is it where there'd
be no changes to the
the seal support because the as i say it
has been
very good the support from the team at
mid suffolk thank you very much chair
thank you thank you councillor eben
we'll pass on your your thanks to the
the whole team any more questions
no does anybody wish to
debate this item
no okay so i'll now ask the governance
officer to conduct the electronic vote
thank you thank you chair
members the vote has now been started
and is in progress in your app
[Music]
thank you that's nine votes for four
chairs so that's unanimous
lovely thank you very much indeed
moving on to item 12
mca 20 41
and this is the solar multi-function
carport
micro generation so this this report is
in
two parts and part one is the public
part of the report
and part two the appendices is
confidential
so uh when we get to the the point
please keep any confidential questions
until we go into private session
so i will now invite the cabinet member
for environment
to introduce the report thank you
thank you very much chairman and um
thank you also um councillor brewster
for um sharing this
report i think it is it is really a
joint reward
for us um i'm very pleased to introduce
our proposals
solar carports to be installed at the um
of the stone market and actually the
sudbury leisure center
in baber which will be a separate
meeting by the baba council
um this proposal reflects the council's
carbon reduction management
plan which um states that we will
explore opportunities for low carbon
energy generation with a view to
minimizing our reliance on the grid
and this will include options for
council-owned land and buildings
and other investment opportunities
furthermore the council
strategic asset management plan
references that the council will
support the delivery of low energy
projects
through proactive asset review of
council-owned estates
or other investment opportunities
i would also add that when we undertook
our
first actions on
carbon reduction and management we
employed groundworks to assess where
our main carbon emissions lie
and we found that our our greatest
emitters are the leisure centers
and the diesel-fueled
waste vehicles so this is where the bulk
of the carbon savings actually can be
made for the councils
so i'm particularly pleased that we're
addressing so-called
the low-hanging fruit first
i'm also really pleased that we've
received um
successfully received some funding to
help us pay for these improvements
as evidence in our report the economy
and regeneration team has successfully
bid for central government's
getting building fund program we have
received
a promise of match funding up to 50 of
the capital grant captured 400 000
pounds per site
um on the provision that this the work
is delivered by
march next year march 2022
this award makes a huge difference to
their viability and deliverability for
the council
and gives a timely opportunity for the
council to demonstrate
its local place leadership in respect of
the economy
and environment i would add that this
project
is essentially a pilot using council
assets and if successful
this whole concept could be deployed by
the council
businesses and developers elsewhere in
the district
to make the far-ranging and local energy
microgeneration effect
and a contribution towards the district
and county ambitions of carbon
neutrality
we have sought specialist advice on the
business case an
optimal system to support the use of
this car ports
and you will probably see that this
project also includes
ev charge points we're looking at
delivering
let me see five fast chargers and one
rapid charger
at least initially along with the solar
charge points
the project is now linking to a recent
further grant for both mid-suffolk and
baber
for other work air source heat pumps
insulation and roof solar
at its leisure estate i'm happy to take
any questions
thank you councillor fleming
do we have a second hand
madam chair i can't get my hand up
counselor i'm very happy to second this
um as councillor fleming has has uh
said that it this is a pilot um
test on both in both councils and
with the with the success of it
i i look forward to further sites being
developed over over the years to to
bring these solar carports
perhaps onto our car parks and and where
else you know
um so yeah i'm very very happy to second
thank you very much councillor brewster
do we have any
questions
cancer field
question about the roof solar um
i'm sure i've read the second paper so
in detail
he it seemed to be unclear whether you
are
actually putting solar panels on the
roof of the leisure centers as well as
on these structures
is it just that it's separated out for
purposes of convenience or is it is is
it
one or the other or both councillor
field were you refer
when you said the second paper are you
referring to the private
one the private one yes if we can take
questions first on the public paper
you know i may be in this one as well
i don't think they i think it's i think
that really is in the private paper
probably okay
i'm happy to hand over to um lee to
comment on that if we can keep anything
from the private session
private yes thank you of course just to
come back on that um
the system that's been optimized for the
site does include one portion of the
roof
which is still being developed it's the
extension um the roof there is a new
structure and it's able to take some pv
so it will be nine
sections of carport plus one section
of roof so far if that helps clarify
thank you yes it does thank you
any more questions on the public paper
okay does anybody have any questions on
the private paper
no okay so um
i did have a question on the private
partner
um
right okay in which case what we'll do
is
we'll go into private session
so item 13 is a resolution to exclude
the public
which term includes the press and that's
to consider whether pursuant to part one
of schedule 12
a of the local government act 1972
the public should be excluded from the
meeting for the business specified below
on the grounds that if the public were
present during this item it is likely
there will be disclosure to them of
exempt information
as indicated against each item
the author of the report proposed to be
considered in part two of this agenda is
satisfied that the public interest in
maintaining the exemption
outweighs the public interest in
disclosing the information
do i have a proposal to go into private
session
um needs to be a cabinet member
councillor brewster
yes happy to propose that madam chair
thank you uh councillor fleming are you
seconding that
i'm happy to second thank you okay thank
you very much
so i'll now ask the governance officer
to conduct the electric
electronic vote to go into private
session
thank you chair okay members you'll vote
to go into private session
is now in progress
thank you members chair that's um nine
votes for
if we could just wait for rob to confirm
thank you everybody welcome back into
the public session
so we are now on item 12 which is mca
20 41 and is the solar multifunction
carport micro generation
and i'm now going to ask
the governance officer to conduct the
electronic vote for this item
thank you
okay thank you chair that vote is now in
progress
um
okay thank you that's nine votes for
that's carried chair
thank you very much so that's the
last item on our agenda for today so the
date and time of the next meeting
is scheduled for monday the 10th of may
at 0 9 30. thank you very much everybody
rob can you please confirm when the live
stream is finished
you